so you have interesting views on
monogamy
i would really
like to hear
i would really like to hear you talk
about what your views on monogamy are
um okay so i spoke about this a few
times and there is a social scientist
by the name of robert p barash who wrote
a book called out of eden
and in that book he
basically he basically said that human
beings are not wired to be monogamous
um
he was saying that
this is his his argument that human
beings are more closer to apes
and apes aren't monogamous like a
certain percentage of apes are not
monogamous
and so
when
quote-unquote cheating happens
it's because of a biological and
a wiring let's say that a lot of men
have and he was also saying that
prior to um western colonization of
the world
most people whether you go to
africa asia middle east were living in
some kind of poliginous or polygamous
type situation and it's only the coming
of the western civilization where
everyone said okay one man for one woman
whereas generally before that people
were living in
you know
multiple type relationship scenarios so
it's like yeah when when he put it like
that i was like oh okay cool because
a lot of women now they wonder why you
know men are cheating men are cheats man
of dogs blah blah and it's like
well
maybe they're not wired that way and i'm
not saying that because i've been in
monogamous relationships
i'm not saying that men cannot be
monogamous
i'm saying that probably a lot of them
are not
but what is happening is that because
i believe women have been sold the dream
of monogamy house kids
white picket fence
my husband mike they've been like that
dream of like prince charming has been
sold
in this society
a lot of
people don't understand why a lot of men
are doing like doing this kind of stuff
and i'm not making excuses for men doing
it i'm just saying a lot i think the
conversation needs to be had because i
think
um
a lot of men are lying to themselves and
also lying to their women because i'm
telling you as a man men know
whether they're monogamous or not right
they know when they get into a
relationship whether they're going to
cheat on this woman or not oh do you
know what i mean so
if they know
can a woman handle being told you know
what i do because don't get me wrong men
love their woman
they can say you know what baby i love
you i want to be for the rest of my life
but
if the rest of my life is the next 50
years
do you think your vagina is the only
vagina i'm going to see for that next 50
years
how realistic is that that's what i'm
asking like how realistic is that do you
know what i mean like could i ask a
question of course so if you're saying
that so then
what if the man were to be like you know
able to be in like an open relationship
would it be i mean you'd have to say
like oh the woman can also do the same
as well can't you um i think so this is
my personal opinion now this is not like
anything but i think when it comes to
women and
that
the
the
murky water on that is
if she was to get pregnant who's whose
baby would it be
yeah do you know what i mean like who's
whose child would it be
would it be the guy's child would it be
that guy's child would you
would it would a man just say okay cool
it doesn't matter it's from him
and it's going to be all of our child
men ain't really built that way i think
there's a reason why you know lions when
they take over a pride they kill all the
children
of
the previous women
it's like because it's like no i want to
start my thing like i don't care about
those [ __ ] like they literally kill the
babies of that thing they're like i want
to start my thing and it's like men
generally are wired differently for
women i think
i just think it's different i don't know
i think it's just hard to compare animal
like mammals because like i would say
like humans were like a little more
intelligent you know yeah like
emotionally
and just like common like i don't know
how to say the word like common sense we
have a little bit more conscious they're
more conscious of animals yeah
so
i wouldn't be like oh you know because
like uh
what is a family of lions kills like
another person's child then that means
like oh like no but how many of you have
been cheating how many of you been
cheated on
you've all been cheated all right
so there's so many women out there
right
there's so many women that i've been
cheated on right yes why
well because we like a small percentage
like if um it's like if you ask 80 of
women what they want in a man they list
20 of men sometimes even less right so
like for example only 15 ish percent of
guys are over six foot like i don't know
the exact number so if you want a guy
over six five six two i'm good
and you're like all right
and like
and let's say you add like you know
money on top of that it's like a smaller
and smaller percentage of guys and then
you know chemistry vibes whatever it is
yeah whatever and then you realize that
you're like competing for like a very
small yeah and that small group of men
understand that they're being competed
for right and so their options are
boundless
and it's like if you're going for those
kind of guys who have boundless options
it's like
do you think they're not going to try
and take one of those options at one
point in time like do you really think
so
and i'm not saying that it's right or
wrong by the way i'm not i'm just saying
oh yeah it happens i have a follow-up
question do you do you believe women are
hypergamous of course they are okay
so
hypergamy is just means like
i would say the best way to describe it
is we want to get the best possible like
maybe we can get yeah we want to date up
so then by that like logic do you think
if we if i have a family and i can do
better
than my husband i should leave my
husband because by nature i'm
hypergamous i don't think you should um
sorry excuse me i don't think you should
leave your husband who you've made a
commitment to
just because you're a hypergamer so so
then would you say the same thing for
men you shouldn't cheat on your wife
that you've made the commitment to just
because yeah yeah i would i would i
actually would i think if you make a
commitment okay
you are bound by that commitment okay i
believe that however i i think a lot of
people make commitments not being honest
yeah and that's why yeah that's true
that is why
the cheating happens and i think if a
guy came to you like you know what baby
i love you we've been together for this
long blah blah but you know at some
point in time i'm just i'm just gonna do
something right
that's more honest but you as a woman
have to now decide whether you're okay
with that and that's being honest what
men do is like no baby you're going to
be arrested the rest of my life is with
you and no one else it's like stop lying
why are you lying
so i think yeah if you make a commitment
and you sign a contract you should be
upheld to that contract i think i think
many people sign that contract
and i think that's why it's so important
to like know who you are i think a lot
of men think oh women need to find
themselves i think that's like more like
stereotype like women need to understand
themselves know themselves but men need
to know who they are yes in order to
make such a commitment like know what
you're know who you are as a person
before you make it come like i can
commit to you but you can't because as a
nobody can
no if he wants to he will but like so to
a certain extent it's not in their
character like no but you know but women
think that a man committing or not
committing such a couple man they are
like you can still be like a man that's
okay with monogamous relationship but
maybe or not maybe you prefer
polyamorous relationships and maybe you
just don't understand that but you're
committing to that knowing you're still
going to be right
right but if you actually understood
yourself studied yourself you actually
put in the time and levels of commitment
to being like you know what this is who
i am and then knowing what you can give
to a woman that's a different thing but
to know to not actually fully put in
that work and then be like you know what
baby i can commit to like i know you
can't like i have a follow-up question
would you guys
be open to an open relationship where
the guy can step out from time to time
but it's just it's just sex there's no
no no no no no but listen listen listen
wait wait wait but you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna go to the bathroom and come
back okay
okay but but all of your bills are
taking care of the rest of your life you
don't have to work you can get like
whatever you want you can have as many
kids as you want like you
the rest of your life you're good you
just have to deal with him stepping out
from time to time
you put up a heartbeat right in there
pearl no no go ahead
um you know i would love
love to say that i would but knowing
myself and the green monster that is in
me
i am a jealous [ __ ]
so
you know like if i i mean you might you
might kill the girl i might no i might
kill the man
i would just be like you know like
i don't know like like why
could you do it and why could i not
because you don't have to pay like
that's the trade-off is is he's saying
you get all my resources you don't have
to work so i get to cheat that's that's
the i might as well just have a sugar
daddy at that point what that's like
well you're the only one that gets his
emotional commitment so all the other
girls they're just like
just physical he doesn't really because
men you know they can sleep with a girl
and not care about her yeah i'm sorry
for me it's gonna be an absolutely not
looking right at the camera so you'd
rather you'd rather
so you'd rather work the rest of your
life and just have a guy that's loyal i
mean i would i do not want to
i would actually love
to be working the rest of my life like i
don't i feel like if i weren't then i'd
just be like
you know i mean like nothing against
housewives but i would just be bored
yeah you know
to answer that question
women don't understand right that men
that men can have sex
with a woman
that's what pearl just said and i
haven't
yeah
i mean women can do it too but a thing
is just like but it's easier for men
though
i would say that what i mean
because we
we can detach ourselves from the act
because it's to a lot of men it's just
an act
why why is that
because
that's just how we're wired like we're
just wired different like we can have
sex with the like
[Music]
i know guys
that have had sex with a woman
and forgot that they even had sex with
her
do you know what i mean like is that
because it wasn't it was nice because it
was it was just that it was just the act
and so
they meet her and they're like
do i know you from
and she's like yeah you do and he's like
oh sh oh oh did we oh oh [ __ ] okay
because it's just an act but you know i
would say just like from personal
experiences that i've been able to
separate
physical and emotional as well right i
feel like just as easily as like any man
can
were you
what i'm not saying women
were you able to do that like right away
or did you kind of have to learn that
like i'm
like i was able to do it like first
first like
five-ish guys you slept with yeah like
you could detach yeah it was just like
you know like a night out okay you know
you just want to let go whatever you
just do it yeah
i mean i feel like it's just like all
power to me you know i yeah
get
what i want without
what is it the luggage right yeah we got
the
baggage can't
you know look at me
right without the like you know oh like
what are you trying to do with this like
just like
just done what i'm done
no i get that but i just think that
generally
men have an
easier time
doing that like even in a relationship
because sometimes a lot of the time
there have been women there have been
married men men that have been in like
committed relationships and they've
quote unquote cheated with someone and
people like you you cheated with her
that's what we talked about last time
when you realize
when you realize you have to be worried
about the ugly girls too
like why
but the reason why it's her because
the face yeah it's like it wasn't
because it was just an act like they
just it wasn't because i was emotionally
involved with this woman or you know
i just wanted to release yeah
yeah a lot of women
don't get that about men but i'm trying
to let them understand like men can just
have sex and just be out but my thing is
like i wouldn't ever want to do that
because like what are the odds if you
catch him doing it once what are the
odds that he's going to stop and like
how do you if he's lying to you about
that how can you trust him about
anything well that's what i'm trying to
talk about yeah lying thing yeah
that's why i talk about the lying thing
it's not about lying it's not being
honest but most people don't want to
have that honest conversation
so like i think it would be different if
they were like say like there's a man
and a woman in a race trip and like
they're an open relationship
i think it'd be fine if they were both
to like tell
them like tell both of each other like
oh yeah i hooked up with this person oh
yeah like just not hiding anything not
hiding any of the details because i have
i do have like a friend that are like
they're married
or friends that are married and they do
have that relationship and it works very
well for them
but so
i forget what like what my what point i
was going to make but i would say like
you know like i feel like that's both of
them like the men and the woman cheat oh
they go elsewhere so outside so they
like
they go out together i've actually been
out together with them
like while they're like
on the prowl
i mean it's just like they're going out
and they're like okay like i might find
someone and they both like tell each
other like is this okay is that okay
and then they just like you know they
there's a lot of communication i think
that's key to making that work i would
say 100 yeah and honestly yeah have you
ever seen 100 sorry no i was just going
to say would that be because you said
cheating would that be considered
cheating if they are both in an
agreement like no no no no no shooting i
would say is if
there's lying involved and then hooking
up behind the back yes not mine involved
if there's not lying
involved
and you know
what like what do you mean
okay okay so
say that
i'm in a relationship and my dude's like
hey yo i'm gonna hang out at
my
friend's house he tells me who the
friend is the girl
but it doesn't give me
or
yeah it doesn't give me like full
details of what's gonna happen is that
would you consider that lying
like doesn't get if
it doesn't give you the full details and
then ends up hooking up with her i would
say that's cheating yeah i would i
wouldn't say that cheating
but
like lying about going to her like not
saying that maybe his ex would be at a
party or something or like something
like that yeah do you oh do you think
that dancing on another guy as a girl
is cheating so like grinding really no
it depends on like your partner's
culture as well like for example i'm
gonna use carnival
for like um what they like their culture
like i feel like if you're going with
the guy say you're not of the same
culture i'm not talking about cultural
dances i'm talking about like grinding
like anna got like a girl girl goes back
that's what she's talking about oh is it
the same thing okay okay okay okay yeah
that's integrated have you ever example
you're in the uk now you're gonna go to
carnival yeah so for example say um
my partner's from the caribbean
carnivals have come in august i feel
like i know you're gonna do like i mean
i'm jamaican i see i'm i don't know
yeah it's for me to understand that
though as well
me as a person even if i'm part of the
culture i'm gonna know that like you're
gonna know i'm gonna go do my thing as
well but it's not
for them in your culture like for them i
don't speak on it maybe you can speak on
that but um it's not like for them in
their eyes it's not cheating she knows
it's not cheating it's more like that's
what they co that's what they do okay
but let's not i'm not trying to do it
under the guise of like culture i'm
talking like some girls go to a bar that
one has a boyfriend and she's grinding
and like twerking on another guy
it's problematic like yeah i would say
yeah
i would say that it's
it goes down to what do they agree to in
the relationship because
a guy may not may not care like oh yo
yeah you can go dance on whoever over
there i don't care about it because you
coming home with me tonight but a girl
may have some may have a problem if
he if she sees her man
and another woman is dancing with him
she may be like uh on that well i feel
like a lot of couples don't have that
conversation and i think yeah and have
conversations
and i think that a lot of guys don't
like i don't know i'll see girls like
with boyfriends like grinding on these
other guys i'm like
would your boyfriend be cool with that
because i i don't know
i'm like if i'm in a relationship and i
go out and i'm with my man i'm gonna
dance with my man about it no no i'm
talking about without it you go out by
yourself
yeah you're saying yeah yeah i
understand i'm saying like
so what if you go out with your girls
i'm not gonna dance on anybody really
yeah
the key thing is she doesn't know
carnival she doesn't know the uk the
carnival she doesn't know carnival
i think the key thing is like basically
the communication relationship like we
need to talk about it from the start
like oh like do you consider this like
cheating or like if i were to do this
like would it hurt your feelings you
know you just have to clarify everything
so that you know like maybe not like
from the start maybe like before you go
out with your girls you'll be like okay
like let's talk about this just so
like if you were to do something then
you know it wouldn't hurt their feelings
and then obviously if you knew it would
then you wouldn't do it
but say like if you don't know and you
do it because you don't consider that
cheating then i think that's a
completely different story
i really do think relationships are
evolving yeah nowadays i think
relationships are not like our
grandparents generation
they're just evolving and i think what
what we can see now is
you know that um
you know that when something's changing
you have that
crazy time when
things are changing and it's like
a bit crazy i think it's hard to talk
about this how to talk about it's hard
to do people don't know what's going i
think we're in that time and i think i
don't know give it another 50 years and
the types of relationships that will be
um that we think are crazy nowadays will
just be normal you know what i mean so i
think we're in that transition stage
yeah that's true there have been you
know i've seen a lot of what is it like
social media couples where it's like two
girls one man yeah i see that they're
revolving
but are they evolving or are they going
back to what they were that's the thing
what are you oh like
that is interesting are they going back
to what they were huh
way back in the day but it used to be
yeah yeah like didn't get caught yeah
are we reverting back to who we are did
we did this point in time in history
just try to show us that as something
different and it's like uh you guys
can't do that go back to what you were
doing like is is that what is going on
here that's that's what i don't know now
we're more open to different things yeah
the world is evolving for example back
in the day like certain things a lot of
things were like more frowned upon like
there were more rules in in like in
place i think you see i don't think that
but it's mostly about people's culture
as well like back in the day it was
more harder and more
harder to be open to who you are whereas
now it's more open and you can't be who
you are
but it's literally all down to that
communication i don't i don't like it i
don't like the way it's evolving i think
because i just grew up in such like uh
old school traditional my because my my
parents
my parents have like they've only slept
with each other and i think there's yeah
in their life yeah and i think and i
think so we tell you always
no no no no
no no they started
that's what that's what everyone says
actually on the internet but i swear i
would bet like my my life i would bet
don't do that i would no i would
have failed no no no
no don't vouch for anyone you don't know
no but you know what i'm not sorry to
cut you though um
um
what i've noticed in
in my life is
people hide things very well
100
and they know how to appear
a one way
and something's going on and i'm not
saying that your parents aren't like
that you know i don't want to i'm not
trying to speak parents at all i'm not
trying to do that but i'm just saying
we don't know
but obviously you're gonna but that's
like how you're gonna view the world
like through your life experiences right
so you know fair enough but i'm saying
like like i have nine siblings
oh they'd be busy
and i just i think i think there's a
level like because they both like
maintained a level of purity like before
they like met each other i feel like
yes yeah that's what i'm saying
my mom
my mom met him when she was 17. that's
what i'm saying like and they built a
multi-million dollar business they had
10 kids and like we live in it like i
feel like they want to adopt me
like you're like
i would say you're one of the lucky ones
like yeah but i think like more that's
not like necessarily the norm that's not
yet
you're not the norm you're like
but i feel like i feel like their
marriage is better because they don't
have all these like like connect like
you know you date someone for two years
and you marry someone else right you
still have that like connection with the
last person
and like how many exes come back and
like ruin marriage yeah and all that
like i feel like their marriage was
better yes because they only have each
other and like i feel like it worked
better that way like when women got
married younger and like we don't have
to date for 10 years and get our hearts
broken like isn't it that's amazing you
know that you're that yeah